the similarities with all kind of
addiction is you get that first good
feeling from using something and your
brain just remembers the good part
whether there's a negative oh I didn't
have any money after that I didn't I
miss rent or whatever your your brain
really quickly forgets that and then it
turns into just this obsession like that
it's really the only thing that matters
that's not I look right over there
earlier it's like where I go like
halfway done that blog I look at it like
it's a strip mine like at first you know
I have these relationships and they're
fruitful and I'm getting stuff out of
them and I will burn these bridges and
strip away the relationships with people
until there's nothing left and then it's
just like skirt you know screw it
whatever you know on to the next one all
you want to do is the drug thing I can't
stress enough of the obsession that's
all that's all it matters ma'am
the only thing that makes any sense and
then life is still happening to you as
this is going on you're not really
consciously thinking about well you know
I don't I don't make this phone call I'm
not going to call them tomorrow then
you're not going to talk them for six
months and that that's going to change
how that person feels about you're not
worried about that and you expect the
next time you talk to someone it just to
be like you talked to him yesterday and
with a lot of people it's not like that
and I think that's a problem with
getting clean too I get afternoon I have
an appointment to see dr. CamLAN okay
you get clean and you're like oh I'm
just going to get detox and things when
you find but you get out and everything
builds up all the real life stuff
because you just haven't been dealing
with it the worst thing is really the
shame in at all I mean you feel shameful
that you've screwed so many people over
it feels shameful that your parents
don't want to talk to you anymore really
and that a lot of people resent you and
you can feel it and and it hurts
[Music]